very FC over its proud 134 year history
Berry managed to survive world wars
countless economic cycles and 26
different prime ministers
but it was driven to the war by
Financial mismanagement damaging the
local economy and leaving behind
devastated fanbase who are still coming
to terms with the loss of their beloved
Club
and it's not just Berry
that the same is true of Macclesfield
town another century-old club and
Rushton and diamonds countless others
like Derby Council County have been
driven to the brink after stretching far
beyond their means and despite the
global success of English football the
game's finances are in a perilous state
the combined net debt of clubs in the
Premier League and Championship is now
around 6 billion pounds
Championship clubs spend an
unsustainable 125 of their revenue on
player wages alone and some clubs face
annual losses greater than their
turnover
many if not most club Owners are good
custodians of their clubs but all too
often we hear of flagrant Financial
misconduct and sustainable risk-taking
and poor governance driving clubs to to
the brink
and owners aren't just gambling with
fans beloved clubs they are threatening
the stability of the entire football
pyramid
Mr Deputy speaker aside from the
financial roulette being wrist on club's
Futures this is also about the way fans
have been treated
over the last two decades too many
lifelong supporters have been let down
ignored or shut out by their own clubs
whether it's in the decision to move
their Stadium to a different part of the
country has happened with Wimbledon FC
or to change kit or badges without fan
approval like when Cardiff owners tried
to change the traditional kit of the
bluebirds from Blue to red
or as we saw with the European Super
League when a small group of club Owners
plan to create a close shop Breakaway
League that goes against the very Spirit
of the game without any engagement with
their fans
Mr Deputy speaker football would be
absolutely nothing without those fans
and yet too often their voices have not
been heard
but we have heard them that is exactly
why I made sure that my first meeting as
Minister for sport was with the fans
groups I heard firsthand how poor
ownership and governance can leave clubs
at the mercy of careless owners and in
our Manifesto we committed to a root and
Branch review of football with fans at
the very heart of that review
that review excellently chaired by my
honorable friend the member for Chatham
and aylesford
highlighted a number of key issues that
urgently needed resolving in football
and today we are acting on its
recommendations with the most radical
overhaul of football governance since
the rules were first invented in a
London pub back in 1863
with this white paper we will do five
key things first we will bring in a new
independent regulator to make sure clubs
are financially resilient
the regulator will operate a licensing
system for all clubs in the top five
tiers of English football
those clubs will have to show they have
sound financial business models and good
corporate governance before being
allowed to compete
and the regulator will also be tasked
with ensuring the stability of The Wider
football pyramid
secondly we will strengthen the owners
and directors test to protect clubs and
their fans from careless owners there
will be greater tests on suitability and
on the source of funds
thirdly we will give fans a greater say
in the running of their clubs this will
include stopping owners from changing
vital Club Heritage like names Badges
and home shirt collars without
consulting the fans first
likewise clubs will have to seek
regulator approval for any sale or
relocation of the stadium and fan
engagement will be a crucial part of
that process
fourthly we will give the regulator the
power to block clubs from joining widely
condemned closed shop Breakaway leagues
like the European Super League
finally we will give the regulator fall
back Powers over Financial
redistribution supporting the pyramid is
crucial and this government has already
committed 300 million pounds of funding
to support Grassroots multi-sports
facilities in England by 2025.
when the financial health of the
football pyramid is at risk and football
cannot sort this issue out the regulator
will have the power to intervene and
protect the game in short Mr Deputy
speaker we are protecting the long-term
success of our national game and
restoring fans position at the heart of
how football is run
I want to reassure members that this is
not about changing the fundamentals of
the game or imposing unnecessary and
burdensome restrictions on clubs in fact
it would not natural we would not
naturally find ourselves in this space
having to regulate an industry that has
enjoyed huge success without government
intervention over many years
however despite the scale of the
problems and the huge harm they cause
the industry has failed to act despite
repeated calls for reform so we have
been forced to step in to protect our
national game this is about taking
limited proportion and action to
maintain the Premier League's position
as the strongest league in the world it
is also about safeguarding clubs across
the country from the biggest to those
single Club towns where football sits at
the very heart of the community
it's a deputy speaker this government
has proven time and time again that we
are on the side of fans we committed to
this review in our Manifesto we stepped
in during covet to make sure English
football was one of the first leagues
back across Europe we got fans back into
stadiums quicker than almost any other
country and we took action under
competition law to support broadcasting
revenues during one of the most
difficult periods sport has ever faced
this secured a hundred million pound of
funding to the game we stepped in once
again to block the European Super League
a competition that no fans wanted when
fans have needed us we have been in
their corner and now we are putting them
right back at the heart of football and
I can bend this statement to the house
yeah yeah thank you Mr Deputy speaker
can I thank the minister for his
statement and for advanced sites of it
firstly I should say that the shadow
secretary of state is sorry not to be
here she managed to keep a diary clear
on all the other days we've been one to
expect the white paper but on the day
it's finally arrived uh she has a
commitment in her constituency can I
Echo The Minister's comments about our
sadness on the passing of John motson
with the loss of motty we have lost a
real football legend today
Mr Deputy speaker football clubs are at
the heart of our communities and
football is a key pillar of our culture
society and economy but has long been in
need of reform
too often decisions affecting our clubs
have been made without reference to the
fans without whom football would be
nothing
historic clubs have collapsed because of
the Reckless actions of owners and the
perverse incentives created by the
pyramids finances and the longer we wait
for change the more clubs are at risk
and even now
South End United are in crisis facing a
winding up hearing next week
there's still no agreement between the
Premier League and the efl on financial
redistribution
and rumors continue about revised
proposals for a new European Super
League so we are regularly reminded that
this is an urgent issue
labor support for football reform and
for a fan voice as featured in all our
manifestos dating back to 2010 which is
why labor welcomes the measures set out
in the white paper today
we'll look at the detail but we strongly
support the key proposal for the
creation of a full fully independent
regulator of English football indeed we
back the implementation of all the
recommendations of the fan-led review
from the beginning
and can I once again thank the honorable
member for Chatham O'Neills Ellsworth
for her leadership in getting us to
where we are today
why did it take us so long to get here
the excellent fan LED review report was
published back in November 2021 when the
government responded last year they said
they backed all 10 strategic
recommendations they delayed two
consumed by chaos in the Tory party and
in the government the promise to
legislate was watered down to the
publication of a white paper the white
paper was promised for months and when
we were finally told we could expect it
weeks ago before recess instead it was
leaked to the Sun newspaper and in the
meantime more clubs have struggled and
come near the brink of collapse so I'm
pleased we are finally making progress
today
although today shouldn't really have
been a white paper it should have been a
bill and it's not clear how much more
we're going to learn from a consultation
on a white paper that wasn't already
explored by the fan LED review which had
wide-ranging fan and stakeholder input
supported by an expert advisory panel
but given Where We Are
labor wants to use
you to Bill as strong as possible
so in welcoming the broad proposals may
I ask the following questions of the
minister firstly on finance
Financial sustainability is at the
center of the fund LED review we need a
regulator with sufficient teeth to
ensure that our game as a whole is
sustainable as well as the individual
clubs
so we look forward to seeing the full
detail of powers the regulator will have
to step in on issues like redistribution
if the football bodies don't resolve
them
what can the minister say about the
reviews recommendations on other
important Financial issues like the
transfer Levy parachute payments or
sustainable player contracts
secondly on fan voice the fan LED review
proposed what was called a golden share
which is simply a requirement that there
should be Democratic fan consent that
actions around Heritage items like Club
colors names badges or relocation
outside the local area how will that
supporter consent be guaranteed
and finally on time scales when the
white paper was leaked the sun reported
that the then Secretary of State wanted
legislation in place for the
2024-25 season
can the minister lay out the
consultative and legislative timetable
that would allow that to happen
the intention to legislate in this
parliamentary session and how soon does
he think we can get a bill passed and an
independent regulator up and running
these are important and fundamental
questions because our national game
needs action and needs change and
football fans have waited long enough
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and can I
first of all say to
um The Honorable gentleman that I'm
really grateful for the support that he
has indicated today I think this is you
know I think we all recognize that
action needs to be taken and I'm very
grateful for that support from the
opposition
um I accept that that you know time has
been taken but it is important to put on
record that these are not simple matters
they are complex and it has been
important uh for us to ensure that we
get this right and I can say that I
haven't been sat on my hands I've been
dedicating considerable hours to this uh
building on the extensive work that the
review did led by my honorable friend he
is right to talk about the finance side
of things of course the regulator will
have the teeth it needs to make sure
that they they are able to ensure that
there is support for the whole of the
game he is right to talk about that and
on fan voice although we haven't gone
down the golden share route the voice of
fans is front and center in this white
paper it will basically achieve exactly
the same thing and it will be a
condition of a license for clubs to
compete in English football and on the
bill I'm extremely grateful to him for
the offer of support and I look forward
to working with him as we try and
progress this through the house and I
call the chairman of the fan LED review
on football governance Tracy Crouch
Dr speaker may I join the front bench in
paying trippy to John motson he wasn't
just a commentator of great football
matches but he was a commentator inside
the head of millions of kids playing
football in their back Garden Mr Speaker
he commentated many times on my Ricky
via esque
swerves around flower pot midfielders
and my Gaza style chips over defenders
before my Clive Allen star cut winning
Glory goals against the back wall his
voice was unique his expertise was
Second To None his sheepskin iconic he
will be much missed
um may I uh just thank the minister uh
for the white paper today it has I know
been a painstaking experience uh for him
but we are here actually due to his and
his officials perseverance the white
paper uh honors and reflects the vast
majority of the recommendations in the
fan LED review for which I and the panel
and thousands of fans who contributed
appreciate I genuinely believe that the
white paper does nothing to threaten the
competitiveness the wealth the
attractiveness of the Premier League but
it will protect English football from
vulnerabilities vulnerabilities that in
the past have had devastating
consequences in the past so I appreciate
that we will now go away and look at the
detail of the white paper and I also
appreciate this Deputy speaker that I
have to ask a question uh when making a
presentation so the only question I do
have for the minister is is he able to
actually set out his vision for the time
frame for the next steps for the white
paper
well again I put on record my thanks for
all the considerable work that my
honorable friend has done in this area
and she is right to highlight the fans I
have to say that they have been in the
Forefront of my mind in all the meetings
that I've had discussing this white
paper and I agree with her also that
there is no threat to competition within
this white paper if anything I think it
will bring about a great deal of
confidence and I hope we'll see even
more investment dare I say from the
right people in terms of the time frame
so we will be doing a very short
consultation and targeted consultation
following the publication of the white
paper today my vision is to get on with
this as quickly as possible and I know
that my right honorable friend the
secretary of state shares that but as
you will expect me to say as
parliamentary time allows but in the
meantime we are also considering the
establishment of a shadow regulator to
do much of the proud parity work uh so
that we there is the the regulator when
actually enacted can get on with the
work straight away yeah yeah
oh yeah thank you miss little speaker
um can I say first of all I welcome the
white paper I think it contains most of
the important recommendations from the
phone let's review now most football
fans in the country are not going to
read this they'll probably have an
understanding where I deliberations here
what they will know however is if we
don't implement this and get it right of
the devastating consequence that we're
for before some clubs in the next few
years that have already fallen in clubs
like bury and that's why it's important
to implement it
just say the secretary one of the most
important things is the distribution of
the enormous wealth of football to get a
fairer uh reflection right throughout
the whole of the pyramid so the the
powers that the regulator may have as a
fallback the minister says I think
they're going to be necessary that's
contained in paragraph 912 of the white
paper where it talks about the regulator
uh deciding on the issues that any
financing would need to address
isn't it more than that the regulator
needs a steer from government and from
this house about what the issue should
be so does the minister accept that the
issue should be twofold at least one
that we have a fair distribution to make
sure the sustainability of all clubs
throughout the pyramid and secondly a
distribution that prevents the cliff
edges such as the parachute payments
which create unfair competition at
various points in the pyramid
uh well again I'm grateful to The
Honorable gentleman for his welcome and
for his extensive interest in this uh
area and it's important work and he is
uh right that we have got to get this
right an implementation of this uh
independent regulator is going to be
critically important and right also to
talk about the distribution we have
secured Powers within there for the
regulator to use should there not be an
agreement by the football authorities we
still urge them to get on with it they
still could come up with a deal and I
sincerely hope that they can do that but
we will be looking as we progress
towards legislation for exactly the
steers that he is talking about so that
we can get on with the uh deal that
everybody is expecting and has waited
far too long to see
and chairman of the select committee
Damon Green Mr Deputy speaker I
congratulate the minister not only on
producing this very long-awaited and
welcome white paper but also in broadly
agreeing with my honorable Phantom
Chatham and elsehood which in all
circumstances is usually the easiest and
quickest way
my conclusion in my experience
um he will be aware the house knows that
the Premier League is one of this
country's most successful businesses
exports and Brands and the key issue for
fans is how much can be squeezed from
this Golden Goose without damaging it so
that we can give proper long-term
sustainable support to clubs lower down
the professional pyramid and indeed the
vital Grassroots of football
or whatever happens however quick the
consultation the regulator is not going
to be in operation for 18 months or two
years so how long is he proposing to
give the game itself to sort out this
key issue of the distribution of money
well can I um thank uh the acting chair
of the select committee and he's right
to point out that of course this the
Premier League is the most successful
league in the world and we have been
really careful that we don't do anything
to damage that as we have been
developing our thoughts within this
white paper he's also right to talk
about the important area of Grassroots
Sport and of course you know my view is
and in every meeting I've been in I have
been urging the efl the Premier League
others to come to a deal and get the
distribution of payments sorted out as
quickly as possible but until we have
the regulator in place it will only be
at that point that the uh the powers
will then be available for a a deal to
be struck but please I urge those that
are in those negotiations to get on with
it and get on with it quick
the courtesy of addressing him correctly
Jamie Stern
thank you Mr David speaker can I
associate myself on my on my party uh
with the sounds that's been expressed
with the passing of John Watson but well
done he's managed his government I think
Karen McGuire the host of The Fighter
football will be very pleased indeed by
what's being said today now it so
happens I'm the the new Scot remaining
in the chamber and I believe that
football is for everyone on whichever
side of the Border you live on
Scotland's gone some way down this road
um can I make an appeal that
everything's done humanly possible to
coordinate with Scotland and Wales and
whoever to make sure there's a a
universal a universality of approach to
this because I think we can learn off
each other and get it really really
right I'm I'm pushing the Scottish
dimension
at The Honorable gentleman is absolutely
right um I'm as a proud unionist I'm
more than happy to work with uh
counterparts and do work with
counterparts in the devolved Nations if
they want to uh if they want to come and
have a lesson on how to deliver
sustainable football we'll happily uh
talk to our Scottish colleagues
and I also welcome the white paper and I
would very much like to congratulate the
the minister and his secretary of state
and and my honorable friend from Chatham
and aylesford for the excellent work
that she and her team did in relation to
the fan LED review I I especially
welcome the proposal for an independent
football regulator for English football
but will the minister please confirm
that the financial powers of the
regulator
which are essential in rebalancing the
game and not just powers of Last Resort
because if they were surely that would
be such a potential lost opportunity
Minister Mr Deputy speaker it's always
hard to answer questions from a number
of your predecessors but as a privilege
to do so
um but she is absolutely right to talk
about the financial support that is
needed for the whole of the pyramid
um I can assure her though that we have
made sure that within the provisions in
the white paper and the powers that the
new independent regulator will have will
be there if there is no agreement but I
still believe that football can come up
with a solution and they need to do so
quickly
live effort thank you Mr Deputy speaker
I welcome the white paper and I pay
tribute to everyone remember uh
Chatsworth but uh I want to take issue
with one uh section of the report it
says here that both the Premier League
and the efl are in agreement the greater
Quantum of cash needs to flow through
the pyramid that's absolutely not true
the position of the Premier League is
that they should continue with the
parachute payments and that is the
impasse in actually getting a fairer
distribution of resources and if the if
the government doesn't understand that
it can stand at the dispatch box and say
it pleads with the two parties to come
together and come to an agreement but
it's just simply not going to happen
because of the intransigence of the
Premier League and we cannot wait for
the the independent regulator to go
through all the process that's set out
in paragraph nine here before it comes
to a decision about what side to come
down on in that argument we need some
urgent action otherwise in the meantime
other clubs could disappear so what is
the government going to do to urgently
address that issue
well I would point out that if we hadn't
actually published this white paper if
we hadn't done the intention of
introducing an independent regulator
there would be no option for bringing
these parties together and making sure a
deal was secured the the detail of that
deal of that deal will be something the
regulator will look at and we will be
looking at issues you know they will be
able to look at issues such as the
parachute payments those are the powers
that the independent regulator will have
Damian Collins thank you
it's wonderful to see ideas being
presented now as government policy that
many of us in this house have been
advocating for more than a decade so in
that regard I fully welcome the white
paper but can my honorable friend tell
me will the regulator have the power to
demand access to real-time financial
information from the clubs and not just
rely on self-reporting of their own
budgets and forecasts because as we know
clubs that are failing often try and
hide the fact that they're failing for
as long as possible and often until it's
too late
yes he's absolutely right and it is
important that the independent regulator
does have access to that real-time
information we are obviously in
preparation for the legislation looking
exactly what we need to do learning
lessons from other Regulators like the
FDA for example to ensure that they have
the powers to look at the proper figures
that the owners have and what their
wealth is where that source of wealth
has come from to give confidence and
stability to the whole of the football
pyramid Rachel Hawkins
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and I too
welcome the publication of the white
paper and absolutely want to agree with
Gary sweet from Luton Town that an
independent regulator will provide clubs
with the fairest opportunity to compete
through sporting Endeavor but also
operate sustainably include supporters
and influence from their communities so
I just wanted to press on the supporters
voice element with the absence of the
golden share mechanism
can I have assurances from the minister
that there will be formal recognition of
the supporters in any Shadow regulator
or regulator to ensure that license
conditions that affect fans so so much
can be considered in a formal sense
listen I absolutely can get that
guarantee so one of the four thresholds
to securing a license to compete within
English football will be the level the
fan interest
um will be an important element of that
so those clubs will have to demonstrate
that they are regularly engaging with
their fans that they're talking about
the Strategic plans they may have for
that club and as I mentioned are the
important aspects such as the club
Heritage throughout this I've I've
really do believe that the fans need to
be front and center of everything with
the regulator is thinking about
Deputy speaker my brother and sister's
whole family are complete football nuts
so I know from them that because I don't
spend every weekend on The Terraces I
shouldn't comment on football but what I
do know is how important football is to
communities and seeing forest green
Rovers fans in nailsworth or match day
all over Stroud District or in schools
whenever I visit is a genuine Joy other
members have raised concerns that I have
about the the speed which the football
wealth will flow down to the lower
leagues but I also want to just raise
and press the minister the fact that
forest green owners forest green rangers
owner a few hours owner wants the
regulator to regulate environmental
performance of clubs as well they are
absolute beacons in this field so would
the minister envisage sustainability
being part of the regulator's work or
the football authorities and would he
meet fgr to discuss this
I thank my honorable friend for a
question and she's right to highlight uh
the the the great uh uh experience that
so many fans at Forest Green Rovers have
each week uh and but primarily the
independent regulator will be focused on
financial stability
um but I can assure her that whenever I
have opportunities to raise issues such
as sustainability I always do so and of
course I'd be more than happy to meet a
few requests
yeah Mary Glenn thank you Mr Deputy
speaker further to what the minister has
said about a redistribution of funds how
will he ensure that funding gets down to
the real Grassroots not just down to the
lower leagues
well I I can assure her that for me
personally Grassroots football
Grassroots sport actually is really
important it is a Force for good in so
many ways it is important for increasing
people's activity levels but it's good
for their mental health and it's you
know it has so many other benefits too
and that is why we have already spent
nearly or committed 300 million pounds
for the provision of Grassroots sport
facilities we will continue to work with
both the Premier League and efl and
others right across sport to encourage
more investments in Grassroots
facilities because we recognize the huge
benefits it brings to to the population
as a whole
speaker uh funds of proper football
clubs like Manchester United in South
River I'm aware there are maybe some
others um were deeply worried about the
European super league and will hugely
welcome the the regulatory proposals to
prevent a travesty like that happening
in the future
um so I thank the government but I know
this is only covering men the men's game
at the moment and I just wonder with let
girls play coming up on the 8th of March
you know Junior schools like Saint Mary
magdalene's in pen with them or St
Catharines in Leyland encouraging women
and girls to get involved what this
review has to say to women's football to
both increase ground level participation
but also ensure that there is investment
going into the ever expanding women's
professional game
well my honorable friend is is right to
raise this important area and it was of
course an important area of work within
the review itself uh I'm pleased to say
that we have set up an independent
review into women's football I think we
can all celebrate the in you know the
the wonderful expansion of popularity if
you like of women's football that we
have seen since uh the lionesses
tremendous uh success and also that I
have been meeting with colleagues within
DFE to talk about the provision of uh
sport for women and girls because we
recognize this as an important area of
work I'm looking forward to that review
concluding and giving its report and we
will obviously give our comments on that
report once it's published Phil McDonald
declare an interest I'm honorary vice
president of Hayes in the early United
Football Club can I turn the minister to
page 50 of the white paper which looks
at enhanced due diligence on sources of
wealth which I welcome completely but
can I ask him in the engagement process
that the government is now under going
to undertake that we also look at other
criteria sources of wealth in particular
source of wealth from for example State
funds Sovereign funds and individuals
associated with the regimes which have
records of Human Rights abuses these are
criteria that are introduced now on the
London Stock Exchange and elsewhere
which need to be taken into
consideration because of the
reputational damage to the individual
Club but also the country as well yeah
and I I thank the right honorable
gentleman for his question
um that is absolutely you know we are
literally going to be looking at all of
these issues in preparation for the
legislation uh and we will of course
look at that as part of the consultation
that will be happening following
publication of this white paper let me
Frank
following years of misery and
uncertainty for fans at local clubs such
as Charlton athletic I welcome the news
of independent football regulator but
come
friend assure my constituents that the
government the regulator will have
sufficient powers to deal with
regulatory breaches and strengthen those
ownership tests
um absolutely and this is why we will be
making sure that the independent
regulator is backed by legislation and
we want to ensure that they do have the
powers that are needed we do need to
ensure that they have uh the sanctions
that are needed so that they can
absolutely do the uh important work that
that we are commissioning them to do and
he's right to have highlighted these
specific areas and of course as we
develop the legislation we'll ensure
that that is as strong as possible
I uh first of all uh thank the minister
uh for a step and then very much welcome
the publication of the white paper on
the strategy outlined uh without your
legs um thriving and also the
responsibility of the minister in
Northern Ireland as an example and
encourages all leaders an ability to
train and play uh uh and also to attain
and Achieve physical fitness
Academy Minister perhaps outline how he
believes we can ensure that all levels
of football can be enhanced through
through the application of the findings
in this report and what this department
will do to help smaller and amateur
leads because it's very important that
they're part of this process thank you
yeah I you know I I think I've mentioned
in the many Westminster Hall debates
that The Honorable gentleman has
appeared in
um time again that you know that those
such leagues as he mentions are
incredibly important uh and I see my job
as not just dealing with the football
pyramid as we've got in terms of the
professional side but all of those
amateur clubs are incredibly important
they do so much good work in our
communities so supporting them will be
incredibly important and I would
consider that they will be featuring
quite heavily in the sports strategy
that we'll be developing very soon
little Origins Deputy speaker football
would be nothing without fans and that's
why I'm so pleased the government are
putting fans at the heart of football
governance today we're sending a clear
message that regardless of who members
support we're all on the same side as
Badness fans in our fight for our club
can I congratulate the minister on the
publication of the white paper which is
World leading and ask while he continues
to support us with ongoing issues at
West Bromwich Albion will he meet with
fan groups that he has joined me in
championing
well can I first of all um pay tribute
to my honorable friend and my honorable
friend from Dudley South who have been
campaigning hard on behalf of their fans
I know that she's been very diligent as
has my honorable friend from Dudley
South I've been more than happy to meet
them as I said my first meeting as
Minister I insured was with fans because
I wanted to hear their voice loud and
clear and I'm glad that through this
white paper their voices will be heard
loud and clear by the regulator
parliamentary group for football
supporters which were the Secretariat of
which is supplied by the football
supporters Association and Kevin miles
the chief of executive is with us in the
gallery today
um fans are the Lifeboat of blood of
clubs not just an asset to be cynically
sweated as was said by mate Ashley Woody
took over Newcastle United about 14
years ago
and I'm really welcome this white paper
and although it's along the way that is
very welcome but before legislation has
passed the minister did see it it is
considering establishing a shadow
regulator who could do some scoping work
to closely analyze what's happening on
the ground now and to start doing the
Preparatory work so that once the
regulator is properly established and
underpinned by legislation they can hit
the ground running so we're now commit
to doing so setting up that shadow
regulator
well first of all I'm glad that the um
honorable gentleman reference Kevin
miles and all those at the FSA they were
the group that I was talking about a
moment ago and I was particularly struck
by some of the horrific stories
fans like football Blackpool fans who
had to boycott their own club for five
years shows the huge sacrifice they were
making and and absolutely there is a
long list I I can assure him that I am
really actively looking at the shadow
board I can't make that commitment right
now but I do understand the merits of us
having one
we've heard very much about the
importance of having good owners and
Ambassador we're very fortunate and we
also see both Works Uptown and retford
United top of their respective leads but
I'm a notch County supporter and we've
pretty much been through it all over the
years I've seen the club in
administration for a record period we've
had unscrupulous owners we've had the
fans try to take over the club and that
didn't quite work out either
um now things are a little bit better
again we're top of our league as well in
no small part to 30 goals from our
non-league Harland Macaulay Lang staff
but the problem here is that the
football authorities have failed time
and time again with clubs up and down
the country whether it's Financial fair
play uh or whether it's with the fit and
proper test so could the minister
reassure us that the independent
regulator will put right many of the
things that the football authorities
have managed to get so wrong over the
years
well I know that there are some within
football that are are being somewhat
critical today of us uh publishing this
white paper and attention to establish
an independent uh football regulator but
they had their chance they've had so
many opportunities frankly to sort this
out and they failed to do so and it is
precisely because of the examples that
my honorable friend rightly points out
and the the difficulties that so many
fans have experienced in the past that
we have stepped in and we will sort this
out hurry remember
thank you Mr Deputy speaker will any
strengthened owners and directors test
overseen by the independent regulator
take into account human rights
violations and will it make a proper
assessment when it comes to ownership
and bids that are likely to be connected
to State ownership
The Honorable lady who raises an
incredibly important point to us this is
not about a foreign policy of course
what we will ensure is first of all we
will know who the owners actually are
and there are examples that I've had
from from some clubs that have no idea
who actually owns the club and that
person will have to go through a
vigorous fit and proper persons test so
that we can exactly examine the points
uh that I think all of the fans want to
see they want to know that their owners
have the best interests of their clubs
just as the fans do
first the speaker at South End United
Football Club is the heartbeat of our
local community but that heart is
currently on life support so will the
minister pay tribute to the shrimpers
trust the shrimpers zone and the blue
voice for all that they've done to keep
South End United going and they will
warmly welcome this paper and having a
greater say on the running of their Club
but will the minister confirm that the
strengthened owners and directors test
in the white paper should mean that
Southend United's current situation
should never be repeated
well can I um also congratulate my
honorable friend and pay tribute to the
enormous amounts of work that she's
doing on behalf of her constituents and
the fans at South End she has been
Relentless in pursuing me on this issue
and I'm sure that the fans will be
extremely grateful to her for that she's
absolutely right what we're trying to
achieve or what we will achieve with the
independent regulator is having a
regulator that will be monitoring the
situation in each of the clubs at a much
earlier stage so that before we get to
the crisis point there can be
intervention if necessary to put those
clubs on a stable footing so they can be
there for the people that are enjoying
it today it can also be there for their
children and their grandchildren
finally the patient James Wilde
it's a deputy speaker and I declare an
interest as a Norwich City season to get
holder in Kingsland Town supporter and I
welcome the white papers focus on a
sustainable and competitive game but
introducing new regulations should be
very much the last resort so we need to
ensure this is a truly proportionate
regime but given the focus on fans all
my writable friends consider proposals
to allow non-league clubs who took out
Sports survival loans the repayment of
which may threaten some of their
viability to convert those loans into
Equity gifted to supporters trusts to
leave a legacy of Greater fan ownership
of community clubs and will he meet me
to discuss this
I thank my honorable friend for his
question he is right that you know it is
disappointing that we have had to step
in here for uh to introduce the
regulation uh but he is also right and
this is why we have taken time we're
ensuring that it is proportionate uh
because we don't want to put too much
pressure certainly on this clubs that
perhaps lower down the league but but do
need to make sure that they are run
properly he's asking me to make a
spending commitment which I think my
colleagues in treasury would be
extremely cross with me for if I
committed to do that but I would be more
than happy to meet with him to discuss
his proposal
thank you minister of members leaving
the chamber please do so quickly and
quietly
secretary Michael Gove
second reading what day
I think Holocaust
in what day tomorrow
we now come to the back bench debate on
the future of NHS it's Staffing and
funding okay doesn't want to move
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and I beg to
move that